サッブ パパッサーサ アカラナン クサラッサー ウパ サンパダーサチッタ パリオダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
はい 今日のあの 心の中を平和で保つ方法というテーマで説法会を行います
今日の説法講演会は 浜口キヨ子様のお布施でご喜捨で行っております
ご自分の誕生日を迎えていて
それから 自分の息子様にも幸福を願いたいという気持ちでありまして
この法性を教えていただきました
そういうわけで 浜口キヨ子様と
それからご家族 ご家族の皆様方に三宝のご加護がありますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
この功徳の力によって
幸福で安穏で平和で幸せで生活ができますように
それから 心の汚れがなくなって
清らかな心を作りまして
智慧が現れますように
涅槃に達することができますようにと祈願いたします
皆様で合掌して 3回サーグーサーグーサーグー
はい 今日はそんなに難しくは喋れません
ですから もし早く終わったら
皆様の自由ないろいろ質問などに答える答えられるだろうと思います
で 簡単なテーマなんですね
テロリズムということは
この世の中でよく流行っていて
人気である言葉にはなっていますね
どこでもテロリストがヒーローとして崇められる世界になっていて
自分の国はね  30年間のテロリストで苦しんでいてね
それでまあ 西洋の国々がものすごい必死になってテロリストを応援して
お金をあげて とにかく国をハチャメチャにしなさいと言っていて
うまくいかなかったんですね
それから直接スリランカ人も攻撃が攻撃を受けるようになってしまったんですね
で 人権侵害やら戦争犯罪やら
あれやこれやとかね 何一つも根拠のない話はね
国連にまで出して まあほとんどストーリー作ってね
文学作品にも出して訴えるってことは面白いですね
この西洋人の人権の考えは
それ終わったら このイスラム人のテロリストがカトリック教会密室一軒に俺らホテルね
380人 400人に近いほど人が死にましたし
今も病院にたくさんいて
これは政治家のイスラム人が応援して
情報をあげて お金をあげてやったことなんですね
だから政府は断固テロリストを守ってやるぞと頑張って
一般国民とカトリック教会のビショップ様がね
どういうことかと 人を死んだことはそんなにも気にしないのかと
ということで 国民の反対があって
それでもテロリストを応援したという証拠はいっぱい揃っているのに
大臣を守ってあげるんですね 3
人ですね  それで国の人々は
国民が怒ったところで
まあこのイスラムの3人に訴えてあったんですけど
まあ何人かが政治家政治やっていたんですね
イスラム教の人々は そこでそのグループ
みんな腹が立ってね 私たちをイスラム人を守らなくちゃいけないテロリストからと
言って 今仏教がテロリストなんです
イスラム人がすごい平和で仲良く人類を愛する人間に仕立てて
で まあ昔のテロリスト
タミル人の場合でも 仏教のお坊さんたちがテロリストやと
よく書くんだけどね 私はよく言ってるのは
まあただ写真 1枚でも出してみてと
ずっと平和のために頑張っているんだけど
我々には世界がいうのはそういう言葉なんですね
だから今問題はどこまで我慢すればいいかっていうことなんです
で まあ世界はブッダの教えはものすごく嫌いですね
それが単純な理由なんですね
だから神様を信じていなかったら愚か者やということで
生きる権利がないんだと
タミルテロリストはカトリック教会の応援でやっていて
イスラムテロリストはサウジアラビアが金出してやってるんですね
政治家に直接お金が来るんだから
そこをわずかなお金あげて
だから まあ何も土地も何も持たなかった大臣さん一人が
今は世界ランクに上がる金持ちなんですね
こういう時は至る所で取って取って取って取りまくっちゃってね
だからそれはすごく正しいというふうに言ってるんですね
そういうことで このテロリズムということは
我々にとってはすごい身近な
ありがたい宗教になっていて
で 仏教はそのポイントについてどのように語っているのかって
まあ昔はテロリストはいなかったんですけどね
はい それでそういう現実的なことをね
まあ置いといて 我々は真理について語ってみましょう
一番大事なポイントは
人間に問題があるんです
わざわざ人間にしたんだけど
だいたい生命 誰にでもある根本的な問題があるんです
自分と違った考え 生き方
意見 信仰 習慣などなど
いっぱいありますよ 服でも入ってますよ
食べ方も入っては 食べるものも入ってます
自分と違ったものは人がやっていると
これは理解できないんです
私はすごい年寄りだから
あの あの 何でしたっけ？かなり昔ね
何年前かわからないんだけど
私はもう 20歳になる前なんですけど
ビートルズという音楽グループがいて
その連中のズボンが これベルボトムって言うんですね
なんか下の方がね 広がっていて
これで若者もその真似しちゃうと
大人が悪口言うわ なんだこりゃ
気持ち悪い かっこ悪い
あれやこれやとかね だから年寄りが着ない
ちょっと違った形の服を着ただけでも
これ理解できなくて批判するんですね
で それである時期でミニ
スカート スカートという女性の服出てきてね
スカートが膝の上 できるだけ上にくるんですね
前は膝から 1センチ  2 センチ辺りでしたけど
これはどんどん伸びていっちゃったんですね
これであの女の子たちが非難受けるわ
受けるわ 受けるわ 受けるわ
そういうことで ただ服をちょっと変わっただけでも
周りの人々にはそれ理解を理解できなくなっちゃうんですね
私も批判したことがあります
あのテトラに来るちっちゃな子供たちも
またみんなミニスカート着てね
私は言ったのね お前らミニスカート着るのは構いませんだけど
この足なんか気持ち悪くて
もうすごい気持ち悪いよと
女はもっといくら格好悪くても美しく演出するべきだと
だから気持ち悪いんだと
しょうがないんですよ
あの猿みたいな足でね
まあいくらか丸めたいい足だったらね
足を見せてもいいんだけど
これ見ただけでゲロが出るような足で偉そうにミニスカートつけちゃって
ちっちゃな子供たちにはどうすることも
子供は自分でやってるわけじゃないし
まあまあ子供のことは気持ち悪いと誰も思わないんですからね
まあ可愛いと思うんだから
そういうことで この信仰などなど哲学などなどではなくて
ちょっと服が変わっただけでも
これはよく理解しない
認めたくはないんですね
認めません これって人間の病気です
大きな問題です なぜかというと
そんなこと言ったからといって
世界は変化することはストップできないでしょうに
だからはっきりと脳みそが壊れている場合は大丈夫ですよ
例えば 女っていうのは美しく自分を見せたいという気持ちがあるんだけどね
イスラム教の女たちがやっぱり袋の中に隠れていなくちゃいけないと
昔は女がもうなんだこりゃ
特にアジアのイスラムの女たちが普通で
頭だけちょっとシャーリからシャーリの長いところから隠しておくだけで
みんなと仲良くしていたんですね
スリランカにいる女はみんな袋の中に入ってるんですね
黒い袋の中に それはなんて素晴らしいことですかと
まあ言っていて だからまあ
まあそれでもスタイルというならばスタイルなんですけどね
私はね まあどこかで言いたい気持ちがあるんですね
で 誰かにね この女たちが体を袋に入れて隠しているのは
ものすごいごっつい気持ち悪い人々だと
すごいひどい皮膚病とかね
にかかっているんだから
そうやって隠せなくちゃあかんよとかね
だからそれを犯罪に使うんだから
だって顔を見えない 目も見えない
外から隠れて犯罪するんだからね
それぐらいは人類のことを心配して批判するべきだと思いますけどね
とりあえず我々にはそういう大きな問題があるんですね
そこで自分の意見 例えば服に文句はない
例えば日本でもね 男たちも耳に穴を開けてピアスをつけることがあって
これを始めた時はかなり言われたんですね
その当時の若者 今はおじちゃんたちですけどね
それでアジアでは必ず女性は耳に穴を開けてピアスつけますからね
それで日本の女の子たちももう穴を開け始めてね
これでお母さんたちがもうこれ我慢できなくて
かなりカンカンにいろいろ言っていたことがあるんです
だから そういうことで
やっぱり言ってるポイントはそういうことなんです
それはあまり問題にはならない
若者は大人いうことをあまり聞かない
で その点では聞かない方がいいと思いますけど
もう何でもかんでも反対してもいけないしね
そこら辺はよく考えなくちゃいけないんだけどね
何であろうとも大人に反対するんだっていうことは
それは極端で それは良くない
一部は大人いうことは聞く必要はないし
一部は聞く必要はあるんですね
一番世界が困っているのは
この考えなんですね 自分の考えと違った考えを持つ人々のことは
まるっきり理解しないだけではなくて
頭イカれてる変人やと思うんですね
要するに自分に関わるすべてが正しいんですね
だって人のこと間違っていると言うならば
自分が間違ってないでしょ
だからそれはみんな真剣に考えないポイントなんだよ
人を批判する人は自分が正しいと思っているんですね
それで逆にそれだけ取ってみたらどうで
私こそ正しいと 世界観が違っていると
まあ病気で言っちゃうと病気に申し訳ないんですね
それぐらい病気なんです
病気っていうのはかっこいいものでしょ
苦しいんだけど 治療したりいろいろして
まあ手当てしてくれますからね
これはもう病気の病気なんですね
気づくことすらしない
病気は気づきますからね
それで治りますね 気づくことすらしない病気だったら
もう一番ひどい病気なんです
だからよく見ると 誰だって自分が正しいと思っているんです
だからギャーギャーいろんなことについて
あれはあかん これはあかん
なんでこんなことするのかとかね
よく言ってるんですね
えーと 激しい洗脳とマインドコントロールがかかっているので
意見違いが間違っているようにしか見えません
そこで我々は基本的にはすごい激しいマインドコントロールにかかっているんです
どんな人間でも洗脳されているんです
それで私は人々を洗脳しているんだと言われているケースがありましてね
私は笑っちゃったんだけど
私はずっと洗脳 マインドコントロールに断然反対の立場でね
自由になりなさいと 自由に考えなさいと言っている人ですけど
それで人が自由に考えることを始めちゃうと
あの坊主に洗脳されているんだという人はどこまで洗脳されてますかね
はっきり言いますけど
頭イカれたある洗脳坊主なんです
それ言ったのは 仏教なら道元の話であると
私は道元って何者かと
あれやこれ あれやこれやと探し求めて探し求めていた人でしょうね
彼も仏教はなんぞやと探していた人でしょうね
いつでしたかね 道元がブッダになったのは
だから道元何を探していたんですかね
だから自分の思想も侮辱するところまで頭がイカれているんです
そういうことで この洗脳っていうのはすごく誰だってかかっているものなんです
そこで自分の洗脳と違った洗脳が入り込むと
洗脳するなよ 洗脳するなよと言い出すだけで
あなたも洗脳されてますよと言いたいんですよ
だけど洗脳されてない人は完璧客観的に物事を考えるはずなんです
では 我々は客観的に完璧に考えるんですかね？誰かさんが誰かさんが言ったことを参考にして言っているでしょうに
それで誰かさんが お釈迦様が言うのは
誰かさんが言ったからといってね
鵜呑みにするなよと はっきりと言う
私 ブッダが言うからといって乗るなよと
自分で調べてくださいと
だから我々はもう何でも知りではないんだから
知らないものしか世の中でないんだから
人から学ぶんですよ それは別に正しいんです
知らないものは人から学ぶ
だからといって その人の話を鵜呑みにして
もう乗ってしまって これしか真理がありません
これこそやと言っちゃうと
もう人間失格なんですね
だからイスラム教のテキストを読んでみると
その洗脳は必ずするんです
これしかない 他すべて認めませんと
あんた信じなさいと もしかつると考え直したならば
あなたは死刑 イスラム教では死刑なんです
宗教が変わると で アポストルというものは認めません
他の宗教はそこまでないんだけどね
追っかけてきて殺すんです
で そこまで頭が狂っちゃうと
もう私は断言的に言いますけど
人間失格なんですね そういうことで
この例えば じゃあ宗教の話から外れて
政治的な 例えば共産主義を信じている人々はいる
そういう人々から共産主義を信じない資本主義の人々はみんな悪いんですね
頭がおかしい それで資本主義こそ正しいと思っている人々から見れば
え？あんた共産主義？なんだこりゃと
そこでその人は捨ててしまうんですね
だから自分の考えこそ正しいってことでしょう
だって俺がそう思ってるんだから正しいに決まってるでしょうと
俺は資本主義が好きだから
資本主義こそが正しい
決まっている はい 終わり
決定と それで堂々と生きてるんだからね
そういうわけで 私たちは激しい洗脳にかかってます
それからこのどうにもならないことはあります
皆様 日本で生まれて 日本で教育を受けて
日本で大きくなったんですね
そうすると 日本文化 日本の生き方
日本の価値観に洗脳されているんです
気づかないでしょ 気づかないで
いつでも日本の方がよろしい
食べ物 日本の食べ物は世界一
服は？日本の服は世界一になるんですね
日本人は喧嘩にはいかないんだからね
問題になってないんだけど
それをもって世界でそこを広げ
もう散らかしちゃうと大変なことになるんです
例えば外国人の前でね
あのね 世界一美味しい食べ物は日本食やと言ってみてください
そうすれば侮辱でしょ
相手に対して お前まずいものを食ってるんだよという話でしょ
美味しいものを食ってるのは私たちだけ
あんた方はもう世界一ではなくて
最低なまずいものを食ってるんだと
それっての人間侵害で
侮辱でしょ でも何のことなく言っちゃいますね
言葉はあまりこんなこと言っていいのかと考えないです
さっと言っちゃう そこは自分の意見だ
自分 日本の文化の中で育てられたんだから
当然日本食事もおいしく感じる
他の食べ物としては これは外国の食べ物ですねという感じで
もうなんか飛びかかって食べる
美味しいと思うことはしないんですね
それすら洗脳なんです
私から見れば なぜ洗脳かというと
人間の自由をそこでブロックされていますね
例えば 日本の正式的な伝統的な祭りの場合は
例えば皇室関係のいろいろ伝統的にね
昔からやっているしきたり
習慣がありまして その時はそちらに参加する人々は猿の尾っぽと同じく尾っぽのあるコート着るんですね
男性は あれって日本の文化ですかと私は聞きたいんだけど
でもそれでなければ天皇陛下の前に行ってはならんという
それ洗脳でしょ 結局は
いくらかしっかりした服装で行かなくちゃいけない
すごい文化的な大事な祭りだからね
それはわかりますけど
なんでテールヘッドテールテールコートでなければいけませんかね
あれ見る限り気持ち悪くない？皆様に気持ち悪くは見えません
何のためにあの尾っぽ長いかわからないでしょ
そんなもんですね 人間っていうのはまだ猿から進化していないんですね
洗脳していないと何もできない
例えば我々人間 みんな母親に洗脳されるんですよ
母親言うことは ちっちゃい時は偉そうに逆らうんだけど
どんどん一人になって
自分が社会人になってくると
何のことなく母親の言うこと通りに生きてみるんです
で 気づかない でもまあ
母親のケースだけ私は洗脳として
まあそれだけは仕方がないんだと
母に洗脳されている されていない人間はいない
で 母の洗脳はなんで私はそこは放っておいてくださいと言うのは
母っていうのは子供の幸福を考えることは問題なく
疑いなく 素直に子供の幸せを考えているんですね
だからその洗脳だけはそれほど問題は起こしませんだけど
頭イカれてる母たちの洗脳で子供たちもイカれた活動をすることも非常に世の中にある
ネットで見たんだけど
この 泥棒する癖がある
ある女たちがいろんな店に行って万引きするんですね
それで子供を連れていくんです
子供にしっかり叱って協力してもらうんです
で そうすると子供たちが泥棒することに洗脳されるでしょう
お母さんやって お母さんが言ったことだからと
全くこれは悪いというふうに理解することはできなくなるんです
それはまれなケースでね
今はもうどこでもセキュリティカメラありますからね
そこを簡単にバレちゃいますが
バレたからといって あの子供が悪い洗脳から抜けるかというと
それはちょっとわからない
ないね そういうわけで
我々には洗脳とマインドコントロールがかかっているんだから
その洗脳されている価値観
価値観セットアップありますね
価値観セット マインドコントロールされて
これがYES これはNO
これは白い これが黒いと
もうセットが頭の中にあるんですね
それ以外は理解できないんです
そこで その自分の価値観セットに当てはまる情報が入ると
一部入れて一部却下 一部入れて一部却下で
そちらにはめない情報が入ってくると
え なんだこれ？と これはありえないと
あなたの頭が悪いということになっちゃうんです
ですから 世の中で皆様の評価から見れば
世界一頭が悪いのスマナサーラです
そういうものなんでも反対するんだからね
何の価値も持ってないんだから
結構私の話は理解よりは誤解する方がかなり多いんです
それにもそこは困ってないんです
全然気にもしない それはまあわかってますよ
もうぶゆきっていうことはね
私たちの意見 見解 生き方などが正しいか否かは確かめたことがない
ないでしょう そんな必要もないでしょう
それが問題なんです ダラダラダラダラ言うんじゃなくて
これが正しいですか？と
昔 私はこれ冗談で言ってることなんですけど
テレビでね 日本食こそ世界一食べ物はないんだとかね
世界一美味しいものはないんだと言うと
もうちょっと調べなさいよと
その気持ちはないんですね
食べた 美味しかった はい
これで決定ではなくて
客観的なデータを出して
まあこういうわけで こういうわけでという風に言った方がいいでしょう
別に日本食は世界一美味しいと言ったって
私には痛くも痒くもないんだけど
私は言うのは 言う場合はもうちょっと客観的にデータに基づいて
あるいは言ってる本人が一つ調べてから言ってくださいと
それはないんです 洗脳で一発で言っちゃいます
ちょっとあの プログラムにちょっとした問題がありまして
この 2回アニメーションに入っています
はい それで確かめてみる場合
自分の見解に異論を持つ人々が現れる場合
無理にでも自分の意見が正しいと言うために
何らかの何らかのデータを出すんです
だから 誰かの攻撃 誰かが攻撃しない限り
自分の意見を考え直すことはしないんです
だから反対意見というのは
だから私はダラダラと反対意見を言っちゃうでしょうね
特に日本のことに反対して喋るんです
何のことない 皆様は日本人だからなんです
別な国民に喋る場合は
その連中のこと反対して喋ってみるんです
なぜならば 私に必要なのは
この洗脳をもうちょっと考え直してくださいなんです
それは考え直してないんです
例えばすごい私は悪口で
日本のお坊さんの仕事っていうのは葬儀屋さんの下請けやと
葬儀屋さんが葬儀やってますけど
一部の仕事はそちらにお金払ってやってもらうんです
下請けでしょ これで明らかに日本の仏教を侮辱したことになりますね
それを知った上でやっているんです
なぜかというと ロボットみたいにやるんじゃなくて
もうちょっと考えなさいということがあって
これはこうやってドカンといった方がえ？となった方がありがたいんですよ
だから私の希望は 日本のお坊様方も
日本国民の平和のために
安全のために 精神的にね
病気にならないために
何か頑張ってよと だって文化的に認められているでしょうに
警察もね 交通違反で人を捕まりますけど
運転している人が日本人のあのお坊さんの服を着ていると
今度気をつけてねと言って
脱走 もう放っておくんです
ですから やっぱり尊敬されていますよ
でも それに値するものは一切何もやっていない
葬儀屋さんの下請けで終わっているんです
それで私がいただいた反応は
私はとんでもない新興宗教を教えているんだと
私は宗教反対ですけど
だから受け止め方っていうのは正しくない
それももっとしっかりと
立って立った方がいいんです
自分の価値観 え？と考えた方がいいんです
そういうことで人はじわじわと自由になっていくんです
洗脳からどんどん抜けて抜けていくんです
結構時間かかる作業ですけど
洗脳から自由になった人は
どんなしきたり 習慣を守るべきか
どんなしきたり 習慣をもう捨てるべきかっていう
自分で判断できるんですよ
みんなやってるからやりますっていうのはね
それってかっこいいね
私はみんなやってるからやってますよと
あんなことをへっちゃらで
お前アホかいと お前猿ですか？と
犬ですか？と言った方が私にとってはやりやすい
みんなやってることやるんだと
やっぱりみんなやっているかやっていないか
それで関係なく ちゃんと客観的に判断して物事をやらなくちゃいけないんですね
なかなかそこまで人類は進化しないという問題もあります
結果は はい それで攻撃受けちゃうと何かしら言い訳するんですね
最近 イスラム人の話を結構聞きましたけど
言い訳するわ するわするわ
一つも理屈 論理が合ってないんです
例えば豚肉食べてはいけないと
ハランやと それは仏教の人が豚肉食べていけない
それはハランですと 何でしょうかと言っちゃうと
私はイスラム人だったら
私は何でしょうかと わからないんだけど
コーランではそれはハランと言ってるんだから
我々はそこをやっているんだよと
そう言われたら洗脳が弱いんです
ではなくて 豚はとんでもない
もう豚は食べることはものすごく汚いものを食べているんだよと
そういうものを食べちゃうと
我々はクソを食べたことになるんだよ
それは健康に悪いんだよと
ダラダラ全て嘘でしょ
だから相手はこの人はもう怒って殺すかもしれません
だから初歩で仏教徒だから議論するのは
そこら辺で丁寧に話をストップするんです
反論できますよ 今人間食べてる豚
豚にはクソを食べさせてないんです
話以外でもないんです
かなり健康で育てられてるんですね
だったらあんた方どうするのかと
微塵も病気がないんだと
健康管理しっかりやってるんだよと
そうするとあの理論崩れるでしょ
だから私が初めから言った通りにコーランでハランと言ってるんだから食べませんとね
ですから 豚をね 絹の座布団に座らせて
コシヒカリのご飯を食べさせて
きれいなキャベツをスーパーから買ってきて料理を作って食べさせても食べられないって
食べないんです なんで？クランコーランにハランって言ってるから
で それ理屈で成り立つのに使えない
言い訳する 言い訳 全部アウトなんです
そこで嘘をつけと言ってるんですね
あの宗教で それで仏教の人たちはニコッと
あんた方言ってることちょっと失礼ね
だってあんた方は嘘ついてもいいでしょ
いえ そんなことはありませんと
それは時々 人が大変な危機的なことになってる場合は
嘘をついてでも人は助ける必要があるでしょうとかね
でも コーランの人を騙ってくるならば
嘘をついてもいいという話ですけど
まあとにかく私たちも同じですよ
あの方々の悪口を言ったのは
自分の国で喜んで起こったんだから
私は腹が立ってます あれほど面倒を見てあげたのに
ひとかけらも恩がない
お寺の土地でも作っているのに
まあだからちょっと取り上げて悪口言ってましたけど
まあ我々も同じことなんです
自分やっていることを言われたら
言い訳して反論するは反論するは一つも成り立ってない
で 反論すると怒る 怒ったら洗脳されていることはもう確かな証拠になるんです
例えばこの花は綺麗ですと
言うと 誰かがなんでこれ綺麗で迷惑やと
目障りやと言ったら怒るんでしょ
だってこれは目障りだという自由もあるでしょうに
花は目障りというあなたがちょっと精神科に行った方がいいんじゃない？とかね
逆に花が美しいと あなたは精神科に行った方がどうですか？と
だからまあシンプルなことででも
私たちは ちょっと興奮しちゃうんですね
それは洗脳ということ
例えばこの文字を逆さまに出したら
皆さんはえー 変だとね
思うんですね 今日はそういう体調が悪くてからくるやろうと思ったんだけどね
あの変だなと はい それはもう逆さまに書くのは変ではなくて
逆さまもいいんだけど
読みづらい 私にもと 言った方が正しいでしょ
今左から右に書いてあってね
次の行は右から左に書いちゃうとちょっと混乱するでしょ
それはなんで素直に言えないんですかね
あ 変ではなくて その瞬間で自分で判断すればどうでしょうか
あるいはこれ 今パソコン時代だから
この文字を逆に鏡で見えるようにすることもできるでしょ
そうすると結構大変ですね
読むのは まあ漢字が入っているとそんなに難しくはないんだけど
英語やら他のアルファベットの文字だったらもう読めたもんじゃないんです
その場合はまあ変ではなくてね
まあちょっと苦労しなきゃ読めないね
これは とかね 言った方が正しいんですが
それは言わないね そういうわけで
私たちは自分の洗脳を守るために攻撃されたら逆に理由を言うんです
それで新たな争いが生まれるだけ
この世で異論が成り立たない見解はありません
これは仏教的な言葉で
どんな意見にも異論が成り立ちますよ
仕方がないんです だから我々は見解を持つのは構わないんだけど
その見解に対して世界は違う見解を持ってますよと
それはイスラム陣も理解してほしいんだけど
あの連中は否定すると
独裁者の人殺しあのモハンマドが言ったんだから
それ以外真理はありませんと
批判しては禁止ですと
だから そういう風になってくると
世界はかなり危険なことになるんですね
しかし 人はこの事実を受け止めません
次に平和運動について考えましょう
不思議なことに 人類 世界の平和を皆謳っています
平和がありがたいと言わない人間はいませんね
面白いことは 自爆テロをやっている人々も平和を願っています
しかし 一時的にでも実現したことはありません
そんな人類一斉に平和が欲しいと言ったら平和でしょ
口先だけで言うだけなんですね
この秘密は 自分の見解に
生き方に皆賛成して従うことが平和だと理解しているからです
それわかってないんです
これは私は初めてではないんだけどね
この講演で発表する文章なんです
私と私が思う平和っていうのは
私の意見に他人が賛成することです
それって平和ですかね
例えば アメリカとロシアが平和のために爆弾を落としているでしょ
今も なんで平和のために
それでシリアに爆弾を落とすアメリカ軍隊は
私たちはこれを抑えなきゃ平和になりませんと
ロシアも私たちは爆弾を落として粉々にしなきゃ平和になりませんと
だからロシア側は自分の見解にシリアが従ってほしい
アメリカがアメリカの見解にシリアが従ってほしい
従わなかったら 両側からもやられちゃうんです
そういうことで 世界平和です
アメリカの危険気に入らないんだから
中国はものすごい 汚い危険な存在なんです
中国 経済大国 大国になったら困ると
私に言えるのは お前ら大国になったいってことでひどい困ってきたんだよと
どちらでもろくでもないんだと
だから ああいう原始思考で俺の意見に従えという汚い考えが平和の歌いなり歌なんだ
日本からも平和運動をやっているグループがいるんです
あのうちわ太鼓を叩きながら
南無法輪でいいよとかね
アメリカ国連とかどこでもいるんです
その人々にいたら この題目を引いちゃうと
大宇宙がなんか変なに頭イカれちゃって平和を落とせるんだと
あの連中のくだらない文句聞いたからといって
みんなそれ聞かなくちゃあかんですかね
結局は俺の意見を聞けという話でしょ
俺の信仰に従え だからこの人々はいかに洗脳されているかというと
人殺しに行って戦争することを応援しながら
平和 平和 平和と だから私の話を聞いちゃうと
ちょっと新しく考えなくちゃあかなくなっちゃうんだからね
だから私が洗脳している羽目になっちゃうんですね
皆 イスラム教徒になれば世界が平和ですと信じて自爆テロ行為をやっています
この ISIS なんかイスラム国家になったら大丈夫やと
あんな原始思考の地球になったら大丈夫で
原始思考の地球になれるんですか？現代は
その人々は このコーランでは
この人 コーランですか
他のテキストはわからないんだけど
芸術反対なんですね 人の顔を描いてはいけないんです
アラブ人の芸術能力ある人々はものすごくたくさんいるんだけど
全部何か模様を描くだけでね
皆様 タージマハルなんか見たことあるでしょ？あのお墓
だからお墓にそこまで金かかるっていうと
頭おかしいっていうこともあるんだけど
でも結構金かかって いろんなデザイン作って美しく作ってます
でも一つもないんですね
人の顔とかなんでもないんです
動物すら描いてないんですね
おそらく 禁止だそうです
神がなんか腹が立つみたいね
だって神が作ったものより美しいものを描いちゃうとね
これ腹が立つでしょ あの悪魔が
なんで俺を作ったよりかっこよく人間の絵を描いたのかと
はい それで彼らの言い訳はそうなんですけど
なんでビデオ撮るんですかね？なんで写真撮るんですかね
いかにして言いたいんです
モハメドの顔は描いちゃうと殺される
で そういう人々を殺しに行く人々はなんのことなくネットで顔を出して
まあテロリストは顔を出せませんだけど
動画は世界中ばらまく
それってコーランに反対でしょう
だから自分のことでももうちょっと理性で考えてほしい
しかし 国教はイスラムである
この国も平和がありません
偉そうに言うんだけど
イスラム国家でも平和がないんです
ほとんど独裁政治です
だからなんだこれはと
私にいるの 頭がイカれているということは失礼なんですけど
激しい洗脳にかかっている
ですから  2 たす 2 は 4 であるとわからなくなっているんです
2 たす 2 は 6 であると洗脳されているんです
自分の意見を他人に強引に押し付けることは平和になりません
人権侵害にはなります
だから人類が平和っていうことが
結局私は本気で気持ち悪くなるんです
組織で大きなマンモス組織でもなく
平和の祈りをしたりすると
私はニコッと笑ってあっち向くんです
やらない なぜならば これ人権侵害なんです
一人一人が独裁者になりたいけど
平和という単語の意味すらわかっていないんです
結局 よくよく見ると 一人一人の人間が自分が独裁者になりたいんです
自分の意見を通してほしいんです
自分の意見に賛成してほしいんです
自分の意見にあ 参りましたと
どけさせてほしいんです
本当のところ この仮面を外してみたら
それが本当の姿なんです
人間の 次に人間がやっていることは犯人探しなんですね
人は誰かに指をさして犯人にしたがるんですね
何か問題やったら これ誰のせい
誰のせい 誰がやった 誰がやったと
そればっかりなんです
起きた問題の原因関係を調べるより
誰かを犯人に仕立てた方が気分がいいんですよ
ああ 逮捕されたんですか
よかったと だからまた同じ問題繰り返すでしょ
人が強盗に入って見つかったことで
その人を殺して逃げて
それで ああ とんでもないことを
早く犯人捕まってくださいとギャーギャーと言う
そこで警察が犯人捕まったら
ああ 犯人が捕まりました
よかったとニュースで流して
それでニュースキャスターたちがその現場に行って泣くんですね
最近もあの瞑想会 宿泊瞑想会
テレビ見ていたんだけどね
なんかこの事件があって
テレビ局はものすごい餌があって食ってること悪い
人の不幸 そこで泣くんです
あの現場のところに行って
現場はもう警察を調べて閉鎖していますけどね
帰りません で 犯人見つけて犯人裁いたからといって問題は消えませんでしょう
例えば人が強盗に入ったならば
それはある個人の問題じゃないでしょう
に なんでこの社会でそういう人間が現れる
現れるのかと そういう因果関係を調べて
似ている因果関係あったら
さっさと因果関係を変えるということが答えでしょうに
犯人見つかったからといってどうにもならん
自分が問題を起こした場合でも
犯人にはなりたくないので弁解を羅列するのも犯人探し気持ちです
そこで自分の間違いがあったら
いろいろ羅列するんですね
言うんですね 犯人になりたくない
しかし 他人ならすごい気持ちよくお前が犯人やって言っちゃうんですね
自分が何者 かと調べないで
人間はいかがなものですかと研究するのです
人間というのは自分が何者かと
私は誰ですかと調べません
調べないで この人類はけしからんねとかね
今の世の中良くないねとかね
私はお前が良くないだけやと
言いたいんだけどね 残念ながら私の前でそういうことはあまり言わない
はい そこでポイントは
私が言うのは 我々は自分が何者かと調べれば
そこで問題は終わりなんです
はい 次以降 アイアムパーフェクトというね
私は完璧 それも我々は洗脳されているんだから気づかないことを私は派手に生々しく今日は出しているんです
何の躊躇も遠慮もなく
私の話でかなり侮辱されたと感じちゃったら
それはありがたいんです
なぜならば それはあなたは洗脳されているんだという証拠は
まあ証拠です 言わないが
そのように思っています
これは人間の あの 何といいますか
世界では言わない単語なんです
言ってはいけない 誰も言いません
みんな嘘を言っているんです
ああ 私はもう大した存在ではないとか
裏はどうですかね だから嘘を言いなさいと洗脳されているし
それは日本に限らず世界みんなそうなんです
世界的な洗脳なんです
ちょっと控えめでとかね
人は不完全ですと言うときは
私は不完ですという素直に認めるのは難しい
トゥーエブリイヒューマンというね
英語のフレーズありますね
人は間違う 間違いを犯すものやとと言っているわりに
人の間違いに対してなんでギャーギャーギャーギャー言うんですかね
私は覚えてますよ 我々の教会の仲間で一人がちょっと間違いが犯しちゃって
私はこれ間違いでしょうと言った途端
すみません ごめんなさいと謝る
それは腹が立たない なんで謝るのかと
これで腹が立ったんだと
あなた これ私が頼んだことを全く間違ったことには何も思わなかった
と 謝ったことで腹が立ったんだと
あれが私の世界では洗脳していない
世界では通じません 人は間違いを犯しますよ
それ私知ってます だからこれ間違いなんですけど
もう一度やり直してくれませんか？それだけ
あ すみません あの すみません
申し訳ございませんとかね
そういうわけで 謝る必要はないんです
本当は 人間が本当に理性があるならば
だって誰だって間違いを起こすんだから
謝って済むわけないでしょ
だから我々の仕事は 過ちは極力少なくする
それだけ極力少なくするだけであって
過ちは一切ない生き方をするそうとはあり得ない
しかし 人の過ちを過ちに指差す時だけ
だが 自分の態度は何ですかね
自分が一度も過ちを犯したことはないように
人が嘘をついて嘘をバレたら
あの態度は何ですかね？あなたのことを信頼できません
あんた約束破りました
あんた嘘をつきました
そう言える 他人に指をさして
自分が約束破ったことない
自分が嘘をついたことはない
自分が人を騙ったことはない
で 何だこの態度はと ですから
人は不完全だという場合でも
そのフレーズを自分に入れないんですね
人は不完全です そんな感じです
人は不完全です こちらに来ないんです
だからそれは I am パーフェクトということでしょ
だから最初にそれ言ったバカも
私含む人は不完全ですと
インクルーマイセン って言わなくてはあかんでしょう
だから文章はガタガタなんです
ブッダの言葉と違います
バランス崩れています
他人の過ちをハイライトして調子に乗って批判するとき
自分も過ちを犯すのだという事実は脳裏にないんです
私は正しいと思うことは人類共通精神病です
だからこれは人類みんなにある病気なんです
はい 次 精神病の仕組みに行きましょう
なんか私もなんか人にすごい失礼に喋ったようなことを一時的にやりましたけど
で この理由は次に言います
この精神病であることは誰もわかってない
だからみんな病気だから
病気見つかることもできない
それに仕組みがあるんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法という無上の情報が流れる
これはこれは純粋仏教に入りました
我々には目耳鼻などなどの 6つの感覚器官があって
そちらに色声香味触法という情報が触れる
これは誰にだって同じことなんです
しかし その情報をありのままに認識しないんです
情報を心で処理して 合成して
捏造して 自分に理解できる
納得できる現象に入れ替えて
それが知識 知ったことにします
一人一人が頭の中で変なことをやるんです
自分に理解できるようにあのデータを捏造するんです
これがこの光のナノ秒の速さで送るんです
例えば 目を閉じてからこの花を見ると
花という認識が生まれるたびに 1
秒のどれぐらいかかると思う？まあ 0.3 秒ぐらいです
やはり 100分の3 で
研究施設でこれ調べちゃいけないんだけど
私は何のことなく言っちゃいますけどね
どこでデータ調べたっても
大体私の値は合っていると思います
で ナノ秒っていうのは
これは我々ヴィパッサナー瞑想というものを教えていますから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ですごい集中力を育てると
ナノ秒は認識できない
あまりも早いんだからね
ある程度で 1 秒の100分の1の出来事 1000
分の 秒の 1,000 分の 1ぐらいの出来事を見ることができる
感じることはできるようになります
だから私たちは遅い 音を聞いても音を感じて
それを音声データにして
それから過去のデータからいろんな概念を持ってきて組み合わせて知識にするんです
時間かかりますよ ですから
知る世界は常に主観です
私は知っている世界は私だけに限った世界なんです
私の兄弟は私と同じくネズソはしません
例えば兄弟二人に聞いたら
あなたの好物はと 同じ答え出てこないでしょ
お姉ちゃんが私はなんとかオムレツ好きだよと
好物だと小さな下の子に聞いたら
まあ私はラーメン好きですよと
好物の場合はなんで同じシブリングなのに
同じ兄弟なのに そこで違う
ということで ネズソは主観なんです
ネズソが我々の知識なんです
そういうわけで 世の中で言ってる知識人の話
平和の話 何一つも当てにならないんです
誰が何を言ったっても当てにならないんです
主観を言いふらしていると
凶暴な人の主観が通るだけ
気が弱い人の主観は誰も聞いてくれない
だから トランプさんが TWITTER でくだらないことを書いちゃうと
それで世界は大騒ぎになる
誰一人もトランプさんは相当おかしいやとは書きません
書いちゃと凶暴だから
たとえ外国にいても捕まります
大統領批判しまったと
大統領批判することは法律違反だったら
どんなバカでも大統領になれるでしょ
だからバカしか大統領にならないという運命になったんです
人類を愛する 生命を慈しむ人はなりません
はい この仕組みはみんなに同じですから
この病気ということは特別ではなく
これすごくノーマルなんです
洗脳されていることってすごいノーマルなんです
だから私の前半で喋ったような感じで
なんか偉そうなことを言ってはならんです
我々は人間に生まれたら
どうしてもその病気にかかっている
だから人々のことを心配して
病気から病気を治したい人々は
完治した人々は人々に優しく
この病気を治す方法を教えるしかないんです
こうしたらあなたの病気は治りますよと
しかし 順番があります
まずあなたは病気だよと説得させなくちゃいけない
それから こういうやり方でこの病気が治りますよと
え？と言ったら 私が同じ治療で今完治していますよとも言えます
はい 続きあります 心地よい音楽は認識しますが
空気の振動が耳に触れて感覚が起こることは認識しない
でしょ？認識したことがある？ないね
あ いい音楽だと 瞬間でもう決まってネズソで終わっているんです
それより先に空気が振動する
耳に当たる 耳も振動する
そこで感覚が生まれる
感覚も同じ振動で 波長で生まれて消えて生まれて消えていくんです
感覚も波で 音も波だから
そうするとそれ知る知る知る知るという知ることたくさん生まれるんです
それまだ音楽聴いてないんです
それからそれをひと束にまとめて
どんな音です あ 音楽だ
あの人の歌だ 私は大好きだとかね
好き嫌いにならないでしょうに
過去の感情を引き起こさない限りは
だから過去の感情を持ってきて
それにも上乗せして なんて心地よい音楽でしょうかって
皆様 心地よい音楽はいくらでも聞いたことあるんだけど
空気の振動を感じたことはないんです
時々若い子たちが感じますけど
このすごいロックコンサートとかね
そういうところで人が倒れるぐらい音量を出してるんですよ
そうするとスピーカーにも出せないぐらい音が出るんです
そこでそこらにいると音になってなくて
なんか空気が体に触れることを感じるんです
その場合は体で感じるんですね
例えば低音の場合は 無理に強烈に低音を出しちゃうと
耳は聞きません それは
それで骨に体で感じるんですね
その時だけですね その時の頭はかなり興奮しているんだから
そんな集中力あるところじゃないんです
美しい花は見えますが
目に触れたデータを認識できません
だってこの花から何かデータがずっと流れているんですよ
スーッと絶えず流れているんです
で 皆様に見えるのはテーブルの上に止まっている花なんです
それは人間に限らず他の生命にもある問題で
だから本当は生命は病気だというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
自分の主観は自分にとって正しい認識です
これがかなりの落とし穴なんですね
間違って認識できないんです
だから自分の頭の中で何か現象を作っちゃうと
それがこれは答えですと
空気が振動したら音にしたって
それを音ということにして仕立てて
それから何々さんの歌というふうに決めるんです
例えば女性の歌なんですけど
これは男性の歌でしょうというふうに認識することはできませんね
まあ例えばおにぎりを食べて美味しいと認識する
猫のために買ってきたカリカリも食べてみてください
カリカリ食べて美味しいと認識できますかね
できないでしょ？だから自分の認識は正しいということになっているんです
これってすごい落とし穴なんです
だから私たちは常に自分の認識が正しい
だから私は見たから 私は聞いたから
それは全然仏教の世界では真理にならない
だからってあんた聞いた？本当に聞いた？私は妄想したからと合っていますよっていうとこはありえないでしょうに
この場合 妄想という単語を使いませんだけど
妄想っていうのは心だけの働きで
これは捏造する 花を見て捏造する
本当は花は見えません
何かデータ触れる 触れたデータを花に捏造する
だからそれで妄想にして
私は妄想したからね これはもう間違いなしって言っちゃうとおかしいでしょうに
我々はそれをおかしく感じないで毎日使ってます
そういうわけで 我々は病気なんですけど
ある程度でハンディなんですね
かわいそうなんですね
花が気持ち悪いという人のことを理解できませんね
自分の認識が正しいんだから
その人は変 間違っている
ちょっとおかしいでしょ
例えば人がソフトクリームに味噌を味噌をかけて食べると
皆様どう思う？女性よく食べるパフェとかなんとかあります
いろんな甘いものを入れて入れまくっちゃってね
そちらに味噌もちょきっとと赤味噌と白味噌 2つ2つ入れておけば
あるんだそうですよ じゃあやめます
では 今の女性の方々は首にネクタイをつけたらどうですか？今の服装に変ね
変 自分でちょっとイメージしてください
前に見える方々 女性の方々は普通のネクタイを
男性のネクタイをつけてみるというイメージしてみてください
直ちに変 あ これ変だと
別に女性はネクタイつけますよ
その場合はそれなりの服でデザインするんです
そういうことで 自分の主観で捏造したイメージが正しいという風になっているんです
違ったものはあると 変だと
おかしいと 私はよく使う
私は美しい あれこれ使わないんだけど
ちょっとバランスが整ってないという言葉を使うんですね
ちゃんとバランス 文章を書く時でも
何か人の 私はイラスト描けませんだけど
人のイラストを見る時でも
これはどうですかと 私は芸術的な知識がまるっきりないんですね
だから私は見るのは見た目的にちゃんとバランスを整えているかないかなんです
色のバランスとかね しかし
それも一つの主観なんですね
色がバランス整えなくてもいいんじゃないですかと思いますけど
時々花見てください その植物とそいつら出してる花っていうのは全くバランス崩れてるんです
でも誰もそれ気にしないね
いろんな花を見てください
植物でしょ 植物の形に合ってますかと
最低こちらのバラがあるかもしれませんだけど
バラの花とバラの あの
何て言いますか 木の方
木と言えないね ああいう場合はプランですね
全くバランスはないというと
時々木がものすごい大きい木ですけど
花っていうのはちっちゃくて
バランス崩れてるでしょう
弱い植物が自分でも支えられないぐらいでっかい花を咲く
そうすると人々は何かスティックをつけて結んで支えてあげなくちゃいけない
これバランス崩れてるでしょうに
で 我々はそれは変だとは思ったことは一度もないんですね
ということは 私が使っているバランスという単語も主観であって当てにならないんです
バランス崩れても構いませんよ
漫画の場合はね 体が蛇で顔が人という漫画あるでしょ？新聞などなどではね
何も言いませんね 誰も
はい えーと コミュニケーション
人間は一種の生命体です
ですから たくさん似ているところがあります
ご飯は食べられますが
草は食べられませんね
これは人間に似ているところなんですね
食べられるから 自分が感じた味を熱層して美味しいと発見する
だからご飯は食べられます
食べる それで味を感じる
この感じた味に美味しいと熱層したラベルを貼る
草は食べられません 食べてみたら味を感じる
しかし 食べられないものだからまずいとラベルを貼る
だから何を噛んでみても味を感じる
味までは客観的なんです
美味しい まずいは自分の主観的な判断です
そこでもハンディ見えるでしょ
いくらなんでも草とかね
硬いようなあちらこちらの葉っぱなんか食べて
なんで美味しいかって感じることはできません
だってこの体がそれを受け止めませんだから
だからキャベツやらレタスとか美味しいと言っちゃう
私はレタス食べてみたら
なんだこりゃと 何の味もないでしょうと
なんで食べているのかと
と疑問に思ったことはいくらでもあります
みんなそれをおいしいと食べているのは
それは体が受け止めるからなんです
そういうわけで どんな人間に聞いても
レタスはまずいという人々はいるかもしれませんだけど
まあおいしいという人々の方が結構あると思います
他人 他の人も同じものを食べて
自分の味の味を味の熱層に美味しいと言う
二人でご飯を食べて 美味しい
このあなた 美味しい そうすると私たちは共通して美味しいという単語が出てくるんです
しかし 中身がよくわからない
それぞれ熱層だから これがコミュニケーションです
このポイントで何かわかる？本当のコミュニケーションは成り立ってないんです
言葉で遊んでいるだけ
はい その そういうことに仏教ではコンベンショナルトゥルースというんですね
これは 日本語でなんとか言うかでよく単語が見つからなかったんです
人類が共通して認めている概念が世の中の知識というものになります
まあ大体みんなコンベンションというのは
みんなお互い まあまあそうでしょうという風に
まあ決めたもの パンは美味しいと
チキンは美味しいとかね
ジャガイモも美味しいとかね
ジャガイモの美味しいということは
人間の間で賛成している
同意している概念なんです
中身はそれほど考えてないんです
世間常識という言葉もあります
これは世間常識というもの
そこでポイントは 我々は世間常識を大事にしなくちゃいけない
でなきゃ 人とのコミュニケーションはできない
できなくなるんです 例えば私がポテトチップス食べて
どうですか？これはもうZという
まあじゃあ分かりやすい B
という味ですよと 相手がどうやって理解するんですかね
私はジャガイモの場合
茹でたジャガイモにはAという味名前を付けていますと
ポテトチップスにはBという名前を付けていますと
スマッシュポテトにはDという名前を付けてますよと
自分勝手につけてても
これはDの味がありますから食べてくださいと言っても誰も理解してくれないね
だから私は世間の常識に乗って
ポテトチップス これ美味しいよ
食べて それからスマッシュポテトを出してね
これ美味しいよ 食べて
それで茹でたまま茹でたジャガイモも皿に乗せて
結構ふっくらと茹で上がったんだから美味しいでしょ
じゃあ召し上がってとかね
そういうふうに世間で決まってる単語を使わなくちゃいけないんです
そういうわけで 我々は世間で決まっている価値観にも乗らなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 一つも真理事実ではありません
そこを区別する必要なんです
しかし 世間常識は世間的に事実真理ですが
結局は捏造の世界です
それは捏造の世界をなんとかコミュニケーション世界に無理やり入れ替えたことなんです
だから私は喋ったからといって
皆様は完璧に私が思っていることは理解しないんです
とにかく共通日本語を使っています
正義体っていうのは仏教でまたもう一つ真理があります
これはパーリ語でパラマッタサッチャというんです
ではありません 正義体っていうのは捏造しなかったデータ
いわゆるデータ 純粋データ
組み立ててごまかしてないもの
本物 だから仏教では真理に 2種類いる
世俗体というコンベンションのトゥルースと正義体
究極の真理 主観と争いは仲間です
そこでみんな人類は主観を持っている
主観あるところで争いがあるんです
主観あって争いはないということは成り立たないんです
唯一の神は誰ですか？と戦って殺し合いやってます
世間でね 唯一の神はあの野郎
この野郎と名前を付けちゃって
もう殺し合いやってます
スリランカのイスラムテロリストたちも仏教と腹が立ってますけど
爆弾テロは教会でやっちゃったんです
で だって一番犯人的で見えるんだからね
唯一神を信じているんだけど
あれは違法でしょうね
ありえない 唯一神はアッラーに決まっていると
そうやって我々はいろんなことで戦っていますよ
仏教でも各宗派では争いがあります
天台宗と禅宗はそんなに仲がいいわけじゃないんです
今はみんなある程度で仲がいいんだけど
自分のしきたり 習慣 信仰っていうのはあまりにも
孤立して孤立と言うんですか
固守して守っているんです
すごく怒るんです 別な宗派のことを言っちゃうと
例えば日蓮系の人々はもうみんなもう邪教やと
ブッダの教え 邪教 そこまで戦いにはなっているんです
しかし 地球が丸いという事実に対して
誰も異論を持ったり戦ったりはしません
禅宗のお坊さんと日蓮のお坊さんはお互いものすごく対立するんですね
もう自分自分たちの宗派の教えがこれでこれでこれだとかね
あのね 地球がどう丸い四角いと言ったら
地球は丸いに決まってる
二人とも賛成なんです
ということは 物事に対して事実真理を知るならば
すべての異論 戦いが消えて平和と安穏になるんです
世界で平和がなかったら
誰も真理を知れないということなんです
自分の主観に凝り固まっているんです
神の名前は何ですか？と聞いたら
ブラフマですか？アホロマッダですか？アッラですか
ヨハですか？とかね 決められませんでしょ
アラビア語でアッラーと決めたからといって
ヘブライ語でユダヤ人がもういい
これはヤハウェに決まっているんだよと
ということは 一人も真理を語っていない
ただ自分の主観 自分の伝統
自分の文化に洗脳されているだけ
インドの人に神の名前はと言ったら
インド人がいろんな名前を持ってきますけど
古い伝統的な神の名前言いなさいと言っちゃうと
ブラフマと言わなくちゃいけないんです
今はヒンドゥーの人 それ忘れているんです
別な名前 今取り上げています
それは全知全能の神じゃないんです
本当は だからそういうのはまあすべて間違っていると簡単に言います
あなたの主観でしょ これはあなたの主観でしょ
ですから 神様の名前と言ったら
うーん 金田一郎ですと言ったっても悪くないでしょ
名前自分でつければ 全知全能の神様の名前は金田一郎でよろしいました
なぜ金田ですか？と 人間も金でいい
すべての財産の大本はそちらだから金田ですと
いくらでも理由を言えるでしょうに
だから日本人一般的に使っている金田は
それは別に普通の名前で
だから今日から神の名前は金田一郎と言ってください
日本文化に合わせて はい
私が出したいポイントは
事実の場合は誰も喧嘩しません
それでお釈迦様は真理を発見しなさいと一言葉で
それで平和っていうのは謳わなくても平和なんです
私 自爆テロというね 変なタイトルなんですね
自我に導かれる生き方が
自分にも他人にも苦しみをもたらすんです
だから私たちは自我っていう自分という中心に生きているんですね
それで自分にも迷惑 他人にも迷惑
ですから 私とは自爆テロっていう意味なんです
よく使ってるで 私 私とかね
はい じゃあ自我について説明します
主観と感情が固まったところ
自我の錯覚が現れます
たくさん主観 瞬間 瞬間
主観いっぱい生まれる
眼耳鼻舌身から主観 ずっと生まれる
この主観と好き嫌い 好み
あれこれ感情を混ぜちゃうと
自我という錯覚が生まれるんです
自我という観念を使って
瞬間瞬間変化して流れる世界と認識機能を一つの個体としてまとめる
そこで私たちは大きな間違いを起こすんです
自我という観念を使う
使って 私は見た 私は聞いたということでまとめるんです
本当は私は見てないんです
見たっていうことは 頭の中のね
ねずそうなんです だからねずそうも瞬間瞬間生まれるんだけど
それをまとめて私は見た
私は聞いたという風になるんですね
そういうことで 何でも固定している感じになっちゃうんです
いわゆる無常ということをわからなくなるんですね
自分は正しいなので 意見
主観だけではなく 怒り
嫉妬 傲慢などの感情も理にかなった正しいものになります
そこで我々は自我があるんだから
私は正しいというスタンスを持ってますね
それで自分が怒ったら怒って当たり前
嫉妬したら嫉妬して当たり前
恨んだらあの人を恨むのは当然なことというふうに思っているんです
自己を破壊するし その結果
自分の行為で周りも破壊します
だから私は人のことを嫉妬する
あるいは人のことを恨む
私は恨んで当然と思っているんですね
それで私は人を恨むことによって私も破壊する
そこで周りも私の恨みの影響で不機嫌になって
どんどん破壊の方向に行ってしまうんです
ですから 私という単語で自爆テロという意味になるんですね
すべてはお釈迦様はすべては燃えているということ
お釈迦様の言葉なんですね
この大丹の経典では 眼耳鼻舌身意
色声香味触法 六色 六感覚
六の識などのすべては貪瞋痴で燃えているのだと説かれています
経典紹介できません 結構難しい経典です
すべて燃えているというんで
お釈迦様が貪瞋痴で だから私は何か見たら
私はそのものに愛着を作る
見たものに あるいは心の中で愛着が生まれてくる
だからどこでも燃えているんですね
要するに人とは轟々と燃える炎なのです
一人一人が轟々と燃えている炎なんですよ
だから炎って破壊するでしょう
貪瞋痴で燃えている人は自己破壊で不幸になります
世界と他人に対して行う
考える 話す 行動するという三行為で外の世界にも火をつけているんです
だから私は怒ってから怒りの言葉を発すると
相手も怒るんです 相手にも火をつけたんです
どんな人でもそうやって喋ること
体の行為 それから考えることによって
世界にも貪瞋痴の火をつけているんです
はい そういう意味で私
自爆テロという言葉を作ったんです
それから最強の洗脳 一番強い洗脳って何ですか？自我の錯覚は最強の洗脳です
これ この花きれい きれいじゃないという人もいる
その程度ではちょっと理解できますね
ご飯はおいしい ご飯は嫌いという人もあり得るね
それぐらい理解できますね
だからそれはそれほど強い洗脳じゃないんです
自我 私がいるということは強い最強の洗脳です
私は正しいと思うから
他人の過ちを微細に探すが
自分自己を観察はしない
そこで私たちは 私は正しいという立場で
人の過ちは微妙にもう顕微鏡で
もうもう倍率を上げて上げて探すんです
しかし 自分自身のことは観察しないんです
他人に指をさして犯人にするが
自分に指をさしません
頑張っています 自分に指をさせないようにと
すべてのテロリストの精神マップは同じです
世の中のどんなテロリストであっても
現在人を殺しているテロリストであっても
精神マップは私は正しい
俺が怒っている だから殺してやる
それだけです だから 特別にある宗教を信仰している人々ではなくて
我々一人一人も同じ精神マップで生きているんです
はい それには最後に答えを出していきます
我々はどうやって平安安穏を作るのかと
今まで問題の説明診断しました
これから治療 治療は早いんです
聞き流す心理の世界 ブッダの言葉はいつでも聞き流しちゃいますからね
貪瞋痴の話になったらしっかりと覚えていますね
はい 犯人捜しのこと スドゥッサタンワッジャンアンニエサンアッタノウパナドゥッダサンパレパレサンイソワッジャニオープナアティアタハブサン
アッタノウパナチャーデーティカリンワキタワサトー
ダンマパダにあります
他人の過ちは見やすい
自分の過ちは発見しがたい
他の過ちを籾殻のように風に飛ばす
これは昔のたとえなんですね
昔はうすで籾殻を取って
こうやって空気に飛ばしちゃうんですね
すると米だけ残るんですね
だからもうあーっちゃすごい光が
埃がね 散らかしちゃうんですよ
だからこの籾殻を昔の人々は風で流したような感じで
人の過ちは言いふらすんです
あのね あんた知ってる？あの人はこういうことをやりましたよとかね
例えば人が座ってて 左足を振っている
あれ 貧乏ゆすりと言うんですね
あの人は病気悪いよ いつでも座ってる
左足を振っているんだからと
それでも十分ですよ 人を馬鹿にするためには
賭博をする詐欺師は負けを隠すように自分の過ちを隠すんです
あのサイコロだって この詐欺師が間違っているという何かごまかしちゃって
もう一度やりますとかね
するんですよ そんな感じで我々は詐欺師なんで
自分の過ちを隠す 他人の過ちは世界中散らかす
だからそれでわかるでしょうね
お釈迦様 自分の過ちを汚いことをやらないで
自己観察しなさいよと
自分が不完全であると理解しなさいよと
自分に貪瞋痴があるのだと
素直に認めて それの処理しなさいよと
アッターナメーをパタマンパティルーペーニメーセーアタンニャマヌーサーセーヤナキリッセーヤパンディト
自分を正しく戒めてから他人にアドバイスをするならば
その人は非難を受けません
これはまたダンマパダの芸なんですね
我々は自分のことを見ないで
人にアドバイスする お説教やる
説教する だから誰も聞いてくれないし
喧嘩になるだけ 物分かりになるだけ
人に言う前に 自分で自分を正せば簡単でしょうに
次のお釈迦様の言葉 アッターナンチェタターカイラヤターナアンニャマヌーサーサティ
スダントーワタドゥンメーダダムエタアッターヒキラドゥッドダモー
他を指導する人は まず自分で実行するべきですと
人に教える前に自分でやりなさいよと
良い人間になってから他を戒める
人をアドバイスしてもいいんでしょ
先に自分がやってほしいんです
なぜならば 自己制御は難しいからなんです
我々は病気なんです 気づかない病気なんです
ですから 自己直しは難しいんです
でも仕方がない それ先にやってください
と まあテロは自己観察しない
ディソーディサンヤンタンカイラーウェリーワーパナウェーリナンミッチャーパニタンチッタンパーピオーナンタトーカレン
敵が相手の敵にすること
敵同士で怒っている人は自分に怒っている相手にする
いわゆる怒り同士で 私もこの人のことを怒っている
その人は私のことを怒っている
そうでない場合もあります
私が怒っているんだけど
相手が怒っていない場合もある
私は相手が敵だと思うんだけど
相手は私のことを敵だと思っていない場合もあるんだからね
ではなくて これは敵同士
怒り同士になったらどうですか
会ったらどうなるんですかね
それよりひどいことは
正しく育てていない心が自分自身にする
そこで私たちは育てていない主観の心を持ってるでしょ
我は正しいという心を持ってるでしょ
こんな恐ろしいこと 敵同士でぶつかったっても
大した恐ろしいことは起こりませんと
まあ誰か殺されるだけで終わっちゃいます
だから自分がものすごい不幸になるんですね
自爆テロで 心は正しく覚醒をしていないことは危険であると説かれたところですね
これは極まりのない危険です
自分の心を清らかにしないことほど
世の中で危険なことはないんです
だから世間の皆様 心を清らかにしなさいと言うなよと
言う前に自分の心を清らかにしなくちゃいけないんです
はい それから現実的平和
努力するのは構わないが
世界平和が成り立たない
頑張っても でも成り立たない
それは現実的なのは自己の平和です
自分自身が平和になることはできます
世界を平和にすることはできません
私は暗い話を言っているわけじゃないでしょ
人類の歴史はどうですかね
ずっとやってきたでしょ
いまだにできなかったでしょ
今 ネット世代で IT 世代
地球が小さくなったと言えるようなこと
では 戦いはどうですか？新たな戦い
憎しみ生まれただけでしょう
新たな非難 侮辱 暴徒 暴徒が生まれただけでしょう
新しいタイプの人権侵害生まれただけでしょう
だからこれはもう成り立たないんです
だから 網で水を汲むことをやめましょうよ
まあ汲んでみるのはいいんでしょ
別に 頑張って でも網で水を汲んでも汲んでも何の結果もないんです
やりやってはいけませんと私は言いません
やりたければどうぞ しかし
何か結果が出るものをやりましょうよ
そこで自己直しっていうのは自分でできることでしょうに
なんでそれだけ後回しにするんですかね
はい 今日からそれだけ宿題でやると
世間のことをいちいち言いふら言ったりして
なんで私は自分をいじめなくちゃあかんかと
例えば人にしっかりしなさいよ
嘘を言うなよ 人を騙すなよと言ってみてください
聞いてくれないでしょ？だから自分が何か嫌な気持ちになるだけ
何か言い返されたらどうですかね
このうるさいあなたは
とかね あんた気持ち悪いと言われたらどうですかね？なんで余計な苦しみ作るんですかね
ですから 黙って自分の心の怒り
嫉妬 憎しみをなくすことをすれば
目の前で結果が出ますよ
だからお腹が空いた人は
たとえ優秀な画家でかもしれませんだけど
キャンバスは持ってきてごちそうの絵を描く
またキャンバス意味がないでしょう
そこら辺何か取って食べちゃえば
お腹が満腹になるんだから
そういうわけで 世直しやめて自己直しっていうことは平和の道なんです
自分の心から怒りを根絶するんです
まず ブッダは他に害を与えることは
たとえ自己防衛のためであっても
これ正しい いけない これは漢字間違ってますね
あかんていけないこととブッダが説かれていますね
世の中で自己防衛なら OK でしょ
それはダメなんです 仏教でダメな人が怒って自分を殺そうとする
しているんであっても
相手を殺してはいけないんです
いかにお釈迦様が平和を語っているのかと
だから自分が怒りをなくす場合は
そう決めなくちゃあかん
私は私を殺す人に対しても怒りは持ちませんと
頑張ります いかに立派な人間ですかね
それだったら それは鋸のたとえで
自分を殺されても犯人に怒りを抱くなかれと説かれています
お釈迦様が言うんですね
すごい乱暴な人々が来て
出家のお坊さんが捕まって逆立ちさせて両手を取って鋸で切ると
お坊さんは何も悪いこと言ってない
悪いことしてないんです
ただ あの人々はちょっとふざけて
ちょっと面白いからやってみようということでやっているんです
鋸で切っているんです
お釈迦様が言うんです
その時でも あなた方はこの犯人に対して嫌な気持ちを作ったら
俺の話を聞いてないね
あなたは という言葉なんです
ナ メーテーサーサナカロ
あなた方は私の教えを実践していない
お釈迦様はどれほど厳しいかと
そこまで我々は怒り 嫉妬
憎しむなく生きなくちゃいかんです
はい それで世直しではなく
世を慈しむ慈しむ 我々は世界のことはそのまま認めて
幸せでありますようにと
人間がみんなのことを考えるとかわいそうでしょ
アメリカのトランプさんもかわいそうでしょ
考えてみれば みんなハメられているんだことに
病気でハチャメチャなことを言ってますよ
だからこの主観という病気にかかっているんだから
病人に悪口を言う人がいますかね
病人に怒る人がいますかね
病気で何もろくなこと
何のこともろくにできない状態で
苦しんでいると怒ってやると
どういうこと？憎む 憎んでやると
恨んでやると これって正しいんですか？目が見えない人がね
あのあれ スティックホワイトね
白いスティックの時で
この人を恨む こいつは目が見えないんだから
この棒をあちらあちら叩いて立てていくんだから
面倒くさい なんだこの野郎と思う
思う人はいるかもね だから世界はそうやって苦しんでいるんです
世界には真理わからないんです
世界が自分の主観で生きているんです
世界は自分が正しいと思っているんです
ですから 私たちは理解して
幸せでありますようにと
うまくいきますようにと
と念じるのは仏教の立場なんです
自分がそこで平和になるんです
あなた 私のことを恨んでいる
どうぞ それなりに理由はあるでしょ
で 私はあなたのことを恨みませんよと
何か困ったことあったら恨んでもいいよ
困ったことあったら言ってくださいと言ったらかっこよくない？それやりたくないんだから
ブッダに悪口を で マーターヤタニヤンプッタン
アーユサエーカプッタマルラッケー
エーアンピサッバブーテスーマナサンバーヴェアパリマーナ
これは我々仏弟子たちにお釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉なんです
母がたった一人の我が子を命かけて守るように
一切の生命に限りのない慈しみを実践する
皆様はどんな態度を取ってもいいんだけど
私にはお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
生命を見たら 母親が自分の一人の子供を守るような気持ちで
人類生命に対して慈しみを抱きなさいと
だから言い訳成り立たないでしょ
あんた黒人だから あんた中国人だから
もういやだいて 韓国人にとってはちょっとやさしくするんだけど
北朝鮮人はとんでもないよ
それはできなくなるんです
生命を我が子のように
見る すべての生命は自我中心に生きているから苦しんでいるのです
病んでいる生命を犯人にするのではなく
憐れむべき存在なのです
ブッダの智慧から見れば
一切の生命は憐れむべき存在なんですよ
はい それでこのチャプターで終わります
智慧を開発する 心の永久的な究極の安穏を欲しければ
智慧を欲しいのです なぜならば
智慧でない限りはあるのはすべて主観です
主観が間違っています
知識は間違っています
すべて合成した 組み立てた
捏造した考えなんです
真理を知ることは究極の平和です
あの地球が丸いということに誰も戦わないね
真理に争いはない 自我で物事を認識するとあべこべの理解になります
あべこべですよ 違った考えになります
当然他人が認めないしね
自分の意見を 反対意見を出して攻撃することも普通です
自分が主観で意見を持っちゃうと
みんな認めませんね 認められないでは
自分にも意見があるんだから
それから元気な人は攻撃までする
それで平和がなくなるんですよ
自分の心の中で 真理を発見しない限り
自分に平和がありません
だから人は意見を持っている限り
自分の意見 自分の主観を持っている限り
心に平和がないんです
だから真理を発見するんです
道は自己観察 どうやって真理を発見しますか？自己観察
人は不完全ですよと偉そうなことを言わないで
私は不完全でしょう どこら辺不完全ですかと
人はだらしないと言う前に
私がだらしない そこを観察するんです
感情で 主観で物事を認識すると
物事は確実にある 自分も確実にいるという捏造が起こります
例えば こちらで花束があると思っちゃうと
自分もいるんですね 本当は花束は捏造なんです
こちらから何かしらの情報が流れるんです
ずっと その情報に触れたんです
そちらには花がなかったはずなんです
花がないはずなんです
しかし 私たちは自分がいるとねつ造するんだから
自分という殻に閉じこまられて
世間の攻撃に構えなくてはならないんです
だから 自我があると いつでも怯えて
世間の攻撃に構えなくちゃいけないんです
自我があると攻撃が受けます
世界は自分を潰そうとします
今 国同士である程度で平和みたいなことをインチキ平和やってますけど
できるなら戦いたいんです
潰したいんです 自我があるからなんです
自己観察でねつ造機能を止めてみます
だから我々は自己観察方法を教えていますからね
それをやってみてください
自己観察すると 我々は頑張ってねつ造機能をストップしようとするんです
ねつ造機能なくなったら
例えば花は見えなくなっちゃって
こちらから来る情報だけ感じる
そうすると花でなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば音楽を聞くんじゃなくて
空気が振動して耳が感じることを観察してみるんです
あ そこで自我の錯覚が生まれるんだと
いきなり発見するんです
自我がなかったと 自我ってねつ造であったと
自分も世界も実体として存在しないと発見するんです
まあそこら辺難しいところですけど
まあさっさと飛ばしちゃいます
というのは これは理解するよりはやった方がやりやすい
自分も因縁の流れ 世界も因縁の流れです
因縁がなかったらこれはない
因縁がなかったら見えることもできない
因縁というのは流れるんです
例えば こちら花があるというためには光も必要でしょう
光も必要でしょうし 目も必要でしょうし
いろいろ因縁の流れ 認識とその
認識とは その瞬間の結果です
認識っていうのはすごいことじゃない
瞬間 瞬間瞬間で認識 認識
認識 認識していくんです
そちらに自我がないんです
変わらない存在は成り立ちません
存在とは瞬間の出来事です
生きるということは ちょっと瞬間の出来事なんです
次別なものなんです だからお釈迦様は結論を出してます
一切は無常苦無我ですと
アニッチャ ドゥッカ アナッタだと
それわかったら誰と戦う？戦うために人がいなくちゃあかんでしょ
私がいなくちゃあかんでしょ
その両方も幻覚であったんだから
無常しかないんだから
戦うことはそこで消えちゃう
永久的に消えちゃう 永久的に心は安穏に達します
それが真理です 争い 対立は成り立ちません
はい その真理を発見すると
そこで瞬間で同時に一切争いが心から消えちゃうんです
誰とも対立は生まれません
そういうわけで 話は終わった
知らないうちに はい ポイントとしてはね
我々は思考妄想しながら思考妄想すると貪瞋痴でやるんです
だからずっと中燃えているんです
中すごい炎で燃えていると苦しいんです
だから苦しくて もういても立ってもいられないんだから
喋るは 行動するは だから周りにも苦しみを与えている
...これは自我という錯覚をなくすことでしかなくならないんです
だから自己観察する人が究極の安穏に達しますという
ほんのわずかなポイントで長く喋りました
どうもありがとうございます
川崎先生 ありがとうございました
では 少し時間  15分ぐらいまだありますかね
えーと 質問などある方いらっしゃいますでしょうか
一番前の方  えっと 私も連続をしないように頑張ろうと思って
今ヴィパッサナー瞑想に取り組んでいるところなんですが
まだまだ全然うまくいってないんでですけれども
ちょっとヴィパッサナー瞑想して
どういうふうに認識できていくのかなっていうことについてお聞きしたいんですけれども
人間は五感情報を脳に取り入れて
脳科学という最新の脳科学でいうと
大体2 30Hzぐらいのタイミングで認識というか
起きるっていうことがわかっているようなんですけども
ということは 今起きた瞬間がだいたい 0.03 秒とか 4 秒とか
それぐらいのタイミングで意識に上ってくるっていうことで
ですから 人間は連続的な情報を離散的というか
0.03 秒ごとに意識に上ってくるという
そういう情報処理をしているようなんですが
今日ちょうどのお話をお聞きして
100 分の 2 秒ぐらい遅れて
そういう意識認識するっていうお話があって
すごく近い数字だなと思ってびっくりしたんですけれども
そこでちょっと疑問があったんですが
脳科学 現代脳科学でいうと
連続的な脳に入ってきた五感情報が
例えば 0.03 秒ごとに間隔を空けて意識に上ってくるということになると思うんですけれども
ヴィパッサナー瞑想とか
そういう瞑想にかけた人は
今の現象を 0.02 秒とか遅れて
それが連続的に意識に上ってくるものなのか
それともやはり脳科学が言うように 0.02 秒ごとに離散的にというか
不連続にそういう情報が入ってくるような認識になるのかっていうことをお聞きしたいと思いました
うーん まあ難しいね あのね
我々は機械も何もなく
自分で自己観察して心をネッスをカットするんですね
プロセッシングデータプロセッシングをやめるんです
それに我々方法は持ってます
でも失敗しますよ もうハチャメチャ失敗する
だから人は失敗するっていうことは
すごい覚悟してないとブッダの実践できないんです
我々もハチャメチャ怒るんです
それに怒っちゃったらアウト
だから仏教的に怒るっていうことは応援することなんです
だからもう失敗しながら失敗しながら諦めず
この自己観察をやっていると
人に ってスピードは違うんです
例えば ナノ秒を発見する人っていうのはほとんどないと思います
ちょっとありえない ブッダみたいな方々はナノ秒連続でも物事を知ったんですね
それはずっと知ってるかではないんです
ちゃんとデータがわかって目が覚めるんですね
あ それかと それで心で主観を作る仕組みがなくなっちゃうんです
それでも世俗体ありますからね
世間と一緒にいなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから 理性の範囲で世間のことも認めて
あ こんにちはとかね お元気ですか？とかね
そういうことも言いますよ
普通にすごい他の人よりはすごい行儀よく生きてはいるんです
だから言って そこに真理あると思ってないんです
例えば 教会などなどに行ったら
帽子を外すべきだと 仏教の真理を知っている人も
神様を信じてないんだけど
教会に入ればちゃんと帽子を外していくんです
そういうことで 大胆なわけもわからない変人を作るんじゃなくて
完璧な人間を作るんですね
それから 科学的な理性的な質問ですから
この時間のスパンどれぐらい発見するのかということは
ちょっと人によって違うんです
で 我々は具体的に人と話しているんだから
それぞれ人が無常を取るところっていうのは
微妙に時間的な違いは
例えば ある人が 0.5 秒で取れるぐらい能力があると
ある人は 0. 3 秒でできるようになるとかね
その程度で十分です この幻覚が破れたら十分です
そういうことで テキストでは理論的にはっきり書いてますけどね
瞬間 瞬間の滅を見なさいと
しかし 瞬間ということは
それぞれ個人の能力でスパンを決めるんです
だから 初めからハチャメチャやってみるんです
それで能力は上がって
上がって上がって 例えばある人が瞬間というのは 0.2 秒かも
もう一緒に修行する 次の人は 0.3 秒で瞬間だと思う可能性はあります
それもあまり問題じゃないんです
そういうふうなことが起こるんです
よろしいですか？ はい
はい では他の方 結構 では後ろの方とかでは
はい 先ほどのお話で 花束のお話があったんですけれども
やっぱりどうしても花束はあるように見えるんですよね
それがないっていうこと
例えばマイクロフォンもありますし
スマナサーラ長老もいらっしゃるっていう風に見えるんですけど
それがないっていう風にはどのように見ていけばいいんでしょうか
それはあるないの問題ではなくて
ここから何かデータが目に触れるはずなんです
そこで そのデータによって目が変化するはずなんです
変化しなきゃどうにもならん
そこで一般的な常識的な知識で反応するって言うんですよ
反応といったって 我々は変化と言うんです
だから 目に何か触れて
目に何か変化が起こるんですね
私は知ってるのはその変化なんです
自分の体に起きた変化なんです
それが それから時間かけてのんびりとマイクロフォンだ
花束だという概念にするんです
その場合も自分の主観
また働くんです 例えば猫にもこれ見えるんだけど
猫にとってはマイクロフォンだという概念は生まれません
猫にもこれ見えますけど
花束だという概念は生まれません
猫は猫の世界で捏造するんです
だったら真理は何なのかと
だからみんな刺激というか
何か戸惑っちゃうんだから
私はマイクロフォンはない
花束はありませんと言ったんです
それはショックを与えるために
このあるないは関係ないんです
因縁によって何かが流れるんですね
それは目に触れて 目に目にも波長が生まれるんです
それが認識になるんです
まず知ることになって
それから概念つけて認識になるんです
これあまりにも早いよ
だからもうあるんですね
我々にとっては だから世間的にはマイクロフォンがある
これは OK です 真理の世界では
マイクロフォンがあるという妄想概念ではなくて
目に色というデータが触れたんです
色は瞬間で消える 皆様知っている世界では光にしていますけど
仏教は光にしてないんです
で 光っていうのは瞬時に消えるでしょ？だからマイクロこの物体を見ているあなたの目に光の速度で変化を送ってるんです
そこを束にして認識にするんです
例えば格子一個触れたらわかってもないね
大量に格子がぶつけてぶつけて痛くなるほどぶつかったところで
その感覚をまとめて あ
マイクロフォンだということにするんです
そういうわけで あるでもないでもないんですね
因縁だというんですね
例えば同じ因縁の流れを作れば
マイクロフォンでないものをマイクロフォンだと思うことはできます
だからマジシャンはイリュージョニストたちがイリュージョンやってるでしょ
あれは目を騙すでしょ
まんまと その人々はこれぐらいデータが入ったら
こいつはこういうふうに思いますよ
知ってるんです だから目にそのようにデータ入るようにする
間のからくりは気づかないようにする
だからイリュージョンイリュージョニストを見て
あ びっくり すごい どうやってしたの？とかね
我々は日常常識に合わせて日常常識にちょっと理解できないことだから
イリュージョニストマジックと言うんですね
だからこの世界はマジシャンであると経典がある
一つの経典に書いています
イリュージョンイリュージョンを作っているんだと
だからイリュージョンのために実際にある必要はないんです
鏡の中に見えるでしょ？自分はいる
いないでしょ だから鏡の中
自分の画像を見るために
鏡の中に必ず物体として画像が入り込む必要はまるっきりないんです
目にはできます そのイリュージョンを作ることは
目にその光が当たるだけなんですね
だから光が当たったら
はい これという感じにするんです
ということは なんかあのやたらとまとめすぎているっていうことを理解して
自分がすることとしては
やっぱりヴィパッサナー瞑想を地道に一生懸命やっていくと
それが実感としてわかってくるという
そうそうそう そういうことですね
我々は何でもまとめちゃう
何でも束にする だから仏教ではまず我々説法するときは分析させるんです
何でもかんでも徹底的に分析すると消えちゃうんです
例えばおにぎりですよという場合あるでしょ
どちらがおにぎり？では
分析しましょう あの あの緑
いろいろ あのなんか海苔な海苔といって単語使いたくなかったんです
で それを外して これおにぎりですかと
え？これは海苔であって
おにぎりではありません
はい 米 1粒取って はい
これはおにぎり いえ これはおにぎりではありません
はい 置いた 次のご飯 1粒
これはおにぎり？ないんですね
そうやってずっとやってください
中で何か丸いもの あれ？なんて言いますか
あの梅干し これがおにぎりですか？と
はい ないね 置いておく
はい おにぎりはどこですか？と
一個一個調べたんです
そうすると ご飯 ある因果法則によって固めて
梅干しも中に入れて 海苔でちょっと外でちょっと化粧したところで
幻覚的におにぎりなんです
それは脳の起こる幻覚なんです
だから組み立てて組み立てて知識になってますから
だったらそれは知識ではないと我々言うんです
世間的には OK 世間的にはおにぎりがあります
実際分析すると 目の前でおにぎりが跡形もなく消えるんです
はい その分析機能は瞑想を実践する人々はオートで使える使えるようにしてやります
だから瞑想する人々には難しいこと言いませんよ
音が触れたらクラクションだ
救急車だと言わないでよと
音だと言ってくださいと
でも初心者には音とは言っているんだけど
本当は救急車でしょうねという問題あるんです
でも頑張ってと そうやっていると
救急車ではなく 耳のところで感じる
イライライライラ感じる
あの音 認識できる そちらに救急車はいりませんね
それでだいたい救急車と消防車の音っていうのはすごいイライラしますね
あまりにも強烈だから
瞑想中 音 音を感じる 感じる
聴覚 聴覚で実況してみると
怒りがなくなっちゃうんだ
イライラなくなっちゃうんです
まとめちゃうとイライラ
うるさいとか そういう風にちゃんと実践でプログラムは起動します
お釈迦様は完璧に語ったと
我々も一生懸命言っているのは心配するなかで難しいことですけど
完璧に語っているんだからね
特に仏道は完全に語っているんだと
だから心配しないで 言っている通りにやれば誰だって成功します
はい 以上です ありがとうございます
あ すいません 最近ちょっと瞑想していてふっと感じるんですけど
慈悲の瞑想で知る無我の境地とヴィパッサナー瞑想をしている無我の境地は同じものなのかということがちょっと疑問に今なってます
あの慈悲の瞑想は普通のサマーディ瞑想と同じですから
ある程度で無我の境地に達して
それで預流果程度ぐらいは悟りに達することもできます
しかし さらにヴィパッサナー瞑想をやって無我発見しない限りは
阿羅漢という最初のステージにはならないんです
だから似ていて似ていないと理解してください
無我ですから似ていますよ
でもあの ちょっとレベルの差があります
はい  お願いします 仕事とかいろんなところで活動をしている時に
できるだけ人と接する時に怒りを持たないように毎日気をつけているんですけれども
その中で高圧的な人がちょっとやっぱりいる時に
いくら自分の心を抑えよう抑えるというか
流そうとしても だんだんだんだん怒りで心が荒れ狂っているというのがわかってくるようになるんですね
そうすると どうにも抑えられなくなって
すごく嫌な気持ちのまま家に帰るということがよくあるんですが
こういう時に高圧的な人に対して
その人に従わなきゃいけない時とか
もしくは自分だけその人から何かお茶をもらうはずだったのにもらわなかったとか
そういったようなことを受けた時に
どのように心をその怒りから少しずつ離れていったらいいか
ちょっとわからなくなっているので教えてください
あの母の歌という思った方がいいんですね
母から見れば 子供たちのだらしなくて
言うことを聞かなくて
わがままで どうにもならんですね
心配して言ってるのに
でも母は子供のことを愛するんです
だから人間にこれ これは出家にしか難しいかもしれませんだけどね
全ての人類がね 我が子のように見るということは
だからまあみんなそういうどうにもならん
高圧的でだらしなくて
自分こそ正しいという態度でね
まあどこでもないんですね
どこまで怒る？そんなものに怒ったからといって解決もしないでしょう
ただ自己破壊するだけで
そういうわけで そういう風なケースの場合も
この人はこういう高圧的で
まあこんな風にしたらちょっと落ち着くだろうと
子供がギャーギャー泣くと
お母さんがなんとかしようしようしよう
全然泣き止んでくれない
いきなりお母さんがトイレ
あ カラスだ！とびっくりして言ってみて
あ カラスだ 子供は泣き忘れちゃって
カラスはどこにいるのかと探すんですよ
だからそこはまあ 私もこの間
ちょっと上 窓からちっちゃな幼稚園とかね
子供たちいろいろ車に乗せていろいろ散歩させるんですね
それであるちっちゃな子供がもう泣いてるんですね
だからたくさんの子供を預かっているんだから
一人一人子供の面倒を見ることも女性何人かにはできないし
まあ一応車に乗せて まあ車っていうのは低く遅い車ですね
というと この子はギャーギャーと泣いてる
私は窓から上見たら 私
窓からこうやって手を振ったんですね
手を振ったら なんのことはない
子供は手を振ってるんですね
泣き忘れちゃったんです
それでちょっと時間 私のところ通っていったら
えっ？私は泣いていたんですねと思い出して
また泣き始めたんです
あれ 泣いていたんだから
じゃあスタートと だからまあ
そんな程度で十分ですよ
だから子供は泣く理由はあるでしょうね
子供にとっては 大人から見ればよくわからない
だから あ カラスだと言った方がいいじゃない
いいんじゃない それで子供の思考パターンがびっくりしちゃって壊れる
あのストップして別な対象に行くんです
なんで泣いたのかと忘れちゃうんですね
はい まあそうやって この我々大人の場合でも
いろんな性格の人々はいるんでしょうね
大人だからもうみんな頑固で固まっているのは決まってるでしょう
頑固で固まって 我こそ正しいとハッキリ決まってるんですね
だからそれを理解して生きてみてください
だからもう高圧的に言ったら
ちょっとなんか自分が嫌だなという自分の価値入れてるでしょ
その自分の価値入れないで
普遍的に見ると高圧的という感じで
この人の取り扱いはこんなやり方やと
そこら辺に例えば虎がいたら
あんたどうする？だから虎の虎は性格は変えてくれませんね
だから虎に対する態度はこれで
人間に対する態度はこれで
子供に対する態度はこれでという風にちゃんと区分けるんですよ
例えば会社で虎っているとしましょう
それで上司にお茶を差し上げて
それで虎ちゃんもお茶どうぞという意味がないでしょ
そういうわけで 我々は人間はそれぞれ固まっているものであると理解して
そちらに必要な態度を自分で考えなくちゃいけない
それで自分がいつでも
なんです 仕方がないんです
だから武道をやる人はいつでも世界のリーダーなんですよ
どうにもならんす みんなしっかりと管理してるんです
でも管理されているとわからないんです
いつでも慈しみで それから理解能力でやっています
でも だから私みたいな年上の人々から見れば
何か言った方がいいということは出てきますよ
間違ってだらしなくて
そのままいいやってことはちょっと責任ありますからね
年上だから その場合 私は直接一度たりとも言わないんです
あんた もうちょっとしっかりした方がいいんじゃない？とかね
怠けるんじゃなくて これやった方がいいんじゃない？とも言わない
本人に理解できるように
なんかかなり回り道で言うんです
それができるだけ笑い話にする
だから私に笑私がからかって馬鹿にしちゃったっていう感じで
本人も笑っちゃって 知らないうちにそれを直してるんです
だから私の家にももう一人若い子が一緒に生活してますけど
若い子はどうしてもだらしないでしょ
物事は取ったところで取ったままで
そのまま で 私はもうこれいちいち言っちゃうとめんどくさいんですね
私はまあまあ ネアンデルタール人も一人いますよと言うんです
それで終わり ネアンデルタールこれネアンデルタール人ですからと
今日も言ったんです ネアンデルタール人は野菜食べませんねとか
野菜も食べなさいと誰が言うんでしょうね
その人の人権侵害でしょうに
それでネアンデルタール言っちゃうと
人はなんとなくいてしっかりとやる
だからしっかりと自分の品物をきちんとまとめて
私も何か言ったらピシッとやって
で もともと野菜嫌い奴ですから
知って小さい時からもうまずは別に野菜も食べなさい
健康にいいんだよと そんな人権侵害の言葉は言いません
私はネアンデルタール人はまあもういろいろ肉とかね
拾ってきて食べていたんだから
昔ね って言ったら  本人がものすごい見事に瞬時に
それは上の年上の人にとっては義務があるんですね
いろいろ教えるね その場合でも
私は年上で 権力者のあれは絶対みたいなね
だから冗談で全てうまくいくんです
我々は社会ではね それを区分けして
区別して 何も言ってはいけない社会
例えば会社とかは まあ何も言った
言っちゃうとまずい 誰もあなたの指導は受けたくはないというえらい態度だからね
それはそれで この人はこういうもの
この人は この人はこういう風にやったら落ち着く
この人の打ち上げる時はちょっと
あの ちょっとぬるい方が好む
この人にはものすごく煙が出るぐらい熱いお茶を出さなくちゃいけないとかね
この人は左に置いたら気分が良くて
右に置いたらなんかちょっと嫌な気持ちするんだよとかね
そういう微妙なところまで観察すれば
だからそれはリーダーになるんですね
そういう人々は だから仏教の人は会社の平社員かもしれませんだけど
社長までいかんですよ
私の教育を受けたある若い子がいて
学校に行ってない 勉強できないやつですけどね
仏教の教えを教えたんですね
こいつは後で運転手さんとしてすごいマンモス会社に入っちゃったんです
そこであの観光バスを運転してたんで
最初はね そこでマンモス会社だから
バスを洗うセクションがいるし
技術のセクションあるし
運転手さんは運転だけすればいい
それ以外は何もやってはいけないと
この人は仕事を見つかって
でも最初にこの私から教えたことがあるんだから
あの自分のバスを自分の手でいろいろ綺麗にして
線香も立てて お釈迦様にお礼をして
えらい態度なんです それで周りのスタッフがそれに文句を言ったんですね
あの仕事もハチャメチャにするんだと
例えばバスをきれいに洗って掃除する人には
行ったらこれ全部やってるんだから
これで管理できなくなるんだよと
会社として社長に言ったみたい
社長は新しく入った人だから
この子を呼んで あんたの自分に与えた仕事だけしてください
でなきゃ このたくさん人々がやってるんだから
この管理できないんだと言ったら
あのね 私がこのバスのおかげで食べて生活していますから
私は誰が何と言ったって
私はバスの面倒を見ましょう
終わり 社長には社長に会うのはみんな怖がっていたみたいですね
何のことなく言ったら
じゃあ社長 あ そう 何の反論もないんでしょうね
自分が運転するバスをものすごく可愛がってあげる
それ何が悪いんですかね
それで大体 1ヶ月間経つと
社長の顧問みたいに何でもこいつに聞く
これはどうですか？あれはどうですか？と
だからもう結構大学出て会計やってる人やら弁護士やらいるんでしょうね
でも何かアイデアが欲しかったら
中学も卒業しないでもう学校から逃げた奴がアイデアするんです
だから私はちゃんと仏教通りに生きていなさいと
これが正しい生き方だと
あんた 世間では負けませんよと
だから仏教はって そういうような不思議な力が不思議ではないんだけどね
慈しみの力なんですね
そういうことで 私は経営したりとして
何人かね もう一番もう社会ではもう全くダメ
こいつはっていうね もう将来性 0 という何人？一人二人選んでちゃんとアイデアしてみる
いたら もう 2  3年  6年経つと
こいつらリーダーになってるんで
もうこの人より何倍も知識ある人を管理しているんです
そういうことで 皆様にもそういう風にね
リーダーシップ取れますよ
平社員であったからといって問題ないんですね
負けてるんですね これは惨めで
自我で壊すのいたと言った途端
自分負けてるんですね
だからそういうラベル貼らない方がいいんですね
ラベル貼らないで ただ
この人にこうすればいい
この人にこうすればいいとかね
だから女の子も男の子も泣いてる場合は
お母さんが女の子にぬいぐるみをあげて
男の子に車のおもちゃがおもちゃをあげる
それだけです それでお母さんがきちっと二人とも管理しているんです
いくらなんでも女の子にもね
あなたも車のおもちゃで遊んでよと言ってもやってくれんでしょうね
女の子にはぬいぐるみでしょうね
男の子にもね じゃあこのぬいぐるみ
はい どうぞ これで可愛がってったらもう捨てちゃいますね
はい そういう風に この周りの人々に迷惑にならないように
そのその人々の狭い性格だから
みんなね それを理解して頑張ってみてください
はい  ありがとうございます
はい それではすいませんが
時間となりましたので
これで質疑応答のコーナー終了したいと思います
はい 最後にこの経を唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン
ドゥッカ バヤンパッターチェニンバヤ
スーカンパッターチェニスソーカー
ホントゥサンディーピパーニノー
よく読めない 苦しみものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えて怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
なくなりますように 一切の生命が幸福ありますように
はい ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカー
ニッバーナパラマンワダンティーブッダ